please welcome my friends
[Applause]
i
i really want to hear from you because
i've been reading the book but i want to
hear it from lily saying
what does it mean be a triangle yeah
absolutely well first of all i had to
fight for this title because my
publisher was like be a what now and i
was like no i promise this makes sense
but i don't know if anyone can relate
during the pandemic it wasn't just that
i had nothing to do it was that without
work and being busy and having my
calendar full i truly started to feel
like i didn't have a purpose and i that
was a really sad feeling to have and i
realized it's because i have never done
the work to attach value to anything
beyond work i have never had value in
just myself and my friendships and my
moments and my peace and so i went on a
mission to build a solid foundation in
my mind you know
yeah
and
i know
foundation is kind of a fluff word but
what i mean by that is a safe space in
my mind that i can return to that was
not tied to any external accolade and so
when i googled strong foundation a
triangle showed up because it's
structurally the strongest shape in the
world with a strong foundation so i
thought i'm going to build my life like
a triangle
okay
and
you know in the book i write about how
this is something we're taught from a
really young age you know in school how
are you rewarded grades then you get
into paychecks and promotions and so
every everything we're taught as a kid
is always this very material tangible
way of growing but then i start to
question as an adult what if i have a
day where i actually
was a lot more patient than i usually am
is that not a successful productive day
because we were never taught that that
is something that should measure growth
it should be you know it should be
you're right and when you're a kid
you're always asked what are you going
to be yes what are you going to do yes
what's going to be your job your life
your occupation and it perfectly
dovetails into i have a clip of your
work from 2014
and so instead of
what are you going to do who are you
going to be i want to look back on it
and then talk about it uh take a look
okay
okay are you not the cutest sassiest
sexiest
by the way i want to be at this party
because it's fun oh my god oh yeah here
we go oh and it's hard priorities as a
young baby
oh yeah baby wow um so you look back at
that you know
what do you think when you see that
so this was pretty early in my youtube
career you know and the toughest and let
me just preface this by saying i love
social media i think it's a great tool
it is how i have my job disclaimer
disclaimer but
it is also a double-edged sword you know
a lot of my career really kind of messed
me up mentally because the only measure
of success was numbers it was views it
was subscribers so while shooting this
video i probably was thinking that how
can i make this trend and how can i make
sure that this thumbnail is really
enticing so it gets a lot of views and
all of that's great and it is important
to run a business but
i would be lying if i said that at the
end of the shoot did i think
did you have fun lily i only just now
started to prioritize fun in my life in
fact when i was backstage about to walk
out i said to myself your only goal it
is not to sit perfectly on the stool it
is not to
speak perfect words it is just to have
fun it is people to go there be yourself
have an authentic connection with
someone and go home and say that was an
amazing memory
[Applause]
i mean
you just have so much to say and and you
take breaks right you advocate breaks
which i really
really love i was with um i'm not name
dropping but i can't help but do it
olivia rodriguez
i know you're so famous
you're so famous
she is and i i'm i i got so much
uh wisdom from this young
woman and we're just having this amazing
conversation and we were talking about
like
how could we if there's meatless mondays
why are there not cell phone free
blogs yes you know sundays like the what
i i i think there should be a mission of
like put it down
walk away and just force yourself away
if it's an hour a day a week a month
you know
how what do you think i know you
practice that absolutely and speaking as
someone who
i have an entire
part of my career and even have my first
book is all about hustle hustle hustle
pull the all-nighters do all the work
and this book is a lot different and i
think the issue is that as humans we've
encouraged to be very all or nothing i
think the internet is very you pick one
side you can't be in the middle but
progress is in the middle you know and
so we don't have to decide between this
mindful life where now we just meditate
for 10 hours a day and you don't ever
work hard versus you work all the time
and never take breaks progress is in the
middle for example right now this week i
am on a book tour and i'm going to do a
lot of press and there probably will be
very few breaks that doesn't mean that
next week i cannot then be like and now
i can turn off a little bit i think we
need to know that progress is in the
middle we can have both things oh god i
love you so much
[Music]